bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france cette prolongation du
confinement le week-end dans
l'agglomération de dunkerque est elle
nécessaire selon vous au niveau
sanitaire je pense qu allez vous savez
les taux s'entassent à dents sur notre
territoire
donc en tant que correspondante en la
chambre de commerce
je peux qu'être inquiet de la situation
sanitaire est bien entendu ça aura des
conséquences économiques et notamment
quant au commerce
comment est accueillie cette nouvelle
par les habitants les commerçants
justement est-ce qu'il la comprenne et
ce qu'ils sont à bout les habitants
comprennent la situation sanitaire les
commerçants et entendus pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux ça pose vraiment des
gros soucis économiques
on peut pas considérer que le
confinement ubi qu'elle n'aura pas
d'impact sur leur sur leur chiffre
d'affaires et ne rattraperons jamais le
chiffre d'affaires dans les ouvertures
de la semaine à samedi perdu pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux notamment les
commerces de vêtements de ski et
habillement c'est un vrai souci tout
leur stock de leur collection va être
bradé donc il ya vraiment un vrai
problème économique
est ce que vous pensez toutefois que ça
va avoir une des répercussions sur la
propagation du colis de 19,7
prolongation du confinement et c'est
difficile à lire moi je suis pas bon
fait pas partie des savants donc
j'espère que ce sera des répercussions
positives
nous avons demandé en tant que
l'organisme consulaire à l'état et au
sous préfet de l'arrondissement les
mesures qu'ils pourraient être pris en
faveur de nos commerçants ces fermetures
pour l'instant nous n'avons toujours pas
de réponse
quelle mesure attendez vous justement
pour ses commerces
nous voudrions alors c'est assez
compliqué que sur ses défenses et des
fermetures ponctuelles donc comme les
décisions qui sont prises au niveau des
territoires
moi je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on ait
aussi des aides qu'ils soient
territorialisée soient gérés par les
collectivités des end et agiraient
qualités qui pourraient être pointés sur
vraiment ce chaos des soucis par rapport
à ces conflits
week-end parce que jusqu'à présent ces
commerces ne bénéficie d'aucune aide
pour arriver à supporter ces
restrictions sanitaires sont censés être
ouvert pour l'instant aucune aide n'a
été proposée par l'état sur ces
commerçants de fermeture de week end
ceux qui sont fermés pour des longues
bénéficient ceux qui sont fermées par
décision administrative
et si en bêta son sens tu à démoniser
mais pas pour ceux qui sont actuellement
fermée le week end
est ce que vous craignez que cette
prolongation de trois semaines ne
s'arrête pas là et qu'il y ait encore à
l'issue de ces trois semaines justement
un nouveau une nouvelle prolongation du
confinement même temps c'était parti
pour le bas-côté de la semaine un départ
qui sur deux week-ends maintenant et sur
promis qu'elle supplémentaire et c'est
pour ça que ces décisions qu'on peut
comprendre sanitaires doivent vraiment
être accompagné par des aides
économiques cinq week-ends pour nos
commerçants c'est c'est dans cette
période si le fan sol de catastrophique
bien entendu ce n'est pas pour ceux qui
sont déjà aidés par le gouvernement qui
est de manière importante à certains
le commerçant depuis mois de décembre
depuis le mois de décembre précise et ce
n'est pas pour eux donc vraiment il faut
se pencher sur leur cas on peut pas
aller contre des mesures sanitaires
c'est pour le bien de la population mais
vraiment il faut accompagner à certains
de nos commerçants voir parce que sinon
ça on aura des fermetures c'est évident
ils nous ont aidés et vous fait part de
cette envie d'être d'être accompagné ces
commerçants une alerte en tant que
chambre de commerce on reçoit l'ogre le
rappel des présidents d'unions
commerciales aussi ils font part de
leurs oeufs dans leurs inquiétudes
je crois qu'il faut les écouter mais ces
aides
c'est comme ce sont des fermetures
ponctuelles et territoriale il faudrait
que ces aides soient gérées par l'état
une dernière question rapidement la
situation en ile de france est elle
aussi critique mais un confinement le
week-end n'est pour le moment écartée
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
ya un an deux poids deux mesures entre
votre région est celle de la capitale
pas écouté je vous cache pas que j'ai un
certain nombre d'interrogations pourquoi
fermer les commerçants qui sont dans les
commercial et pas ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur
bien sûr on peut toujours regarder le
verre à moitié plein ou à moitié vide
moi je il ya une décision de l'état sur
un certain nombre de territoires hors
jeu laisse à l'état
on leur décision on peut toujours
trouver sa juste ou pas juste en
fonction de l'endroit où l'état prend
des décisions le moi je respecte
félicité par l'état mais l'état doit
tenir compte aussi l'état de notre
économie et venir en appui à ces
commerçants qui sont touchés aujourd'hui
ce aura des impacts
c'est vrai pour les commerces
d'habillement c'est vrai pour
l'hôtellerie il faut ces fermetures des
week-end auront des impacts sur sur
votre économie clairement merci beaucoup
pour vos réponse françois lavallée je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la chambre de commerce et de l'industrie
littoral au de france merci à vous